an english rose here in northern ireland
potentially
a thing of the past
at this garden center in belfast roses
and rhododendrons are sourced from
england
but that's come to a crashing halt since
the northern ireland protocol
and czechs in the irish sea came in all
these plants are coming from england
and we've been bound from england for
years and years now we cannot get them
because of new rules and regulations and
what are they telling you
really what they're saying is any plants
has been grown with any soil in it
if there's any bark in the mix they will
not let us bring them through
every packet of seeds you see here comes
from england and suppliers have told
robin
that due to the new rules they won't be
able to supply things like
tomato seeds beetroot carrot or
lettuce all unavailable to customers
under
the new trading rules and it's problems
like these for businesses like this
that has led the dup to call for the
scrapping of the protocol
party leader arlene foster told boris
johnson as much today
before this exchange in the house of
commons
tea and sympathy will not cut the
mustard
so what does the prime minister actually
going to do
will he legislate if necessary to remove
the impediments to trade
in northern ireland and will he be a man
of his word and allow businessmen in my
constituency to
bend the unnecessary documentation that
he told us
we could been prime minister be the
unionist we need you to be
we will do everything we need to do mr
speaker
whether legislatively or indeed by
invoking article 16 of the protocol uh
mr speaker to ensure
that there is no barrier down the rsc
triggering article 16 could override the
irish sea checks but would be hugely
controversial
especially after brussels embarrassing
u-turn on using the provision last week
cabinet minister michael gove meanwhile
wants an extension of light regulation
grace periods
until 2023 ahead of further talks the
european commission's vice president
said the protocol is a cornerstone of
the brexit deal
and an absolute priority for the eu
the high level wrangling means little to
the business community in northern
ireland
you know we've been lobbying our local
politicians we've been sent by the
westminster
and really we need them to look at the
risen regulations
and you know relax some of them just six
weeks since the brexit deal was done
and once again northern ireland and
trade are the focus of intense talks
stephen murphy's sky news in belfast